hello everyone and welcome to the only
game that was finished in classical uh
in the round six of this year's Norway
chess it is who is not having the
greatest tournament he is currently uh
second to last uh versus Fabiana corvana
uh who even though he lost the previous
game is still in the lead so let's check
it out it's quite a wild game uh in the
uh interview after the game one of the
players said that at some point he had
no idea what was going on on the board
and as the title suggests uh you guys
will have a chance to figure it out but
uh well he may or may not have found it
over the board so let's check it out uh
Notre back has the white pieces and he
opens with Pawn to E4 we have a pretty
standard line that we've seen I don't
know how many times even on this channel
Bishop to B5 Dory Lopez is on the board
Knight F6 so uh standard Berlin defense
D3 uh Bishop to C5 and now Bishop
captures and C6 the capture so
everything
um perfectly standard Bishop back to D6
we always mentioned that you have to
defend the E5 Pawn somehow whereby by
moving the queen to A7 or Knight to D7
or pinning the Knight with Bishop to G4
so Bishop to D6 all very standard Knight
B to D2 uh Bishop to E6 and now Knight
to B3 this is a a favorite in classical
of not only uh norderbeck with the white
pieces but also of Fabiano with the
white pieces because they both had this
exact same position and they both had it
against the exact same player so here a
pawn to B6 and now uh there is a game
that noderbeck played against Levon
arunan he had the white pieces here it
was played in the Tata steel tournament
this year where Queen to E1 was played
uh but also Fabiano had this exact same
position against Levon arunan in the
American Cup this year where he played
Bishop to G5 now
um uh Fabi was able to beat level
whereas Levon uh was able to get a draw
against Northern but here we have sorry
not that here we have Knights the G5 by
another Beck and it is now already as of
move 9 then we have a completely new
game which is very exciting as this is
the Berlin defense so let's check it out
Bishop to G4 of course not allowing the
Knight to be traded for the bishop
attacks the queen and the nice F3 with
Bishop to H5 and the king the H1 getting
the King off of this down signal we have
Knight to D7 now preparing to kick away
the Knight with F6 F6 is um a tricky
move to play in many openings but in in
Berlin you pretty much always play it so
don't be weirded out by it so Knight to
F3 Knight to H3 Pawn to F6 and now
Bishop to E3 we have Queen to E7 uh and
Knight the D2 a lot of forcing around
here Knights the C5 and Knight the C4
putting pressure on the bishop but also
the knight at some point if the bishop
moose can come to E3 then the F5 F5
would be beautiful for this Knight so
Knights the E6 and now Knight to G1
re-maneuvering both of the knights we
have Pawn to G5 and Knight the E2 now we
have Bishop back to F7 clearing up the
path for the H1 to be pushed and queen
to E1 we have fun to H5 and now Knight
captures and D6 trading the Knight for
Bishop C captures on D6 if I'll be very
happy about this he gets to undouble his
pawns uh then maybe he can execute D5 in
the future we have quanta A4 and now
Pawn to H4 grabbing more space on the
king side Honda A5 and now Pawn to B5
with Pawn to H3 and pawn to A6 now so
the the the
queen side is closed the the king side
is sort of closed in the center uh well
breakthroughs are definitely possible
and here okay one could definitely
consider B4 as one could in pretty much
all position but we have the immediate
D4 by anotherbeck and fiber replies with
Pawn to C5 now if B4 was on the board
then C5 would not be as pleasant so upon
to C3 uh and King to f8
not uh not deciding to Castle but rather
the king will be safe on fa we have Rook
to D1 uh and King to G7 we have Queen to
F2 and now Rook a to C8 preparing to
open up the C file and then maybe Drop
The Rook all the way to C2 uh that will
be an excellent
um uh Square for The Rook so Rook to The
Rook to D2 We have Queen to C7 and now
Rook back to A1 defending that A5 Pawn
that the queen is harassing Rook H back
to d8 and now only Now Pawn to B4 so
okay Fabi trades on d4c capture C
captures on D4 and queen back to E7 we
have Rook 8 D1 doubling up on the D file
and Rook back to h8 it's a very uh weird
move uh I don't know if it's meant to be
an attacking resource of some sort maybe
uh maybe The Rook will come to G6 in the
future maybe you want to re re-maneuver
this Knight or maybe move the king and
then maybe bring the Knight all the way
here so I have no idea what Rook Rook
the a chain does um uh obviously it's uh
it it does something so here Rook Queen
back the one we have rooked the C4 a
very nice Rook Cliff putting more
pressure on the D4 pawn and the B4 pawn
and D captures an E5 we have D captures
on E5 and now Rook to D6 not going for
Rook to D7 right away as then Queen
capture some B4 happens so Rook to D6
preventing Queen captures on B4 and not
just the Rook to d8 offering a queen
trade and once again exposing the
Queen's path to the to the B4 Pawn
sorry about that
uh just a second there we go
uh so after Rook to did we have root
capture 78 Knight capture 78 and now
Pawn to G3 Fabi uh another bike not
satisfied with um some sort of a draw
here uh he wants to attack Open up The
Path towards the black king and open up
the position and uh Fabi has to be very
careful about what he chooses does he go
for the B for Pawn or the C except this
um uh opening of the position on the
king side because if you play Rook cap
for some B4 uh you run into Rook
captures on d8 and okay it's not like
you've lost the pawn uh because black
can also play Rook captures on e4 for
example if captures I need for Queen
capture 78 and then G captures an H4 but
the G captures an H4 and it's hard to
say whether you can do something you
can't touch this Pawn if you play Queen
captures on H4 then Queen to D1 check is
very annoying you have to play Knights
the G one then the bishop comes to G6
you have to defend uh it doesn't look
like you're making a lot of progress but
still after this G captures an H4 move
if anyone is to be preferred here it is
is white however after G3 we have H
captors on G3 first now comes Knight
captures and G3 and the bishop to E6
putting pressure on the H3 Pawn but
Queen to D2 now the Knight is hanging so
you have no time to capture on H3 Knight
to F7 and now Bishop to C5 now attacking
the queen and defending the pawn on B4
we have Queen to E8 and now Pawn to H4
and this is a a very very tricky
position where I will just show a few
lines that are incredibly interesting
what happens if G captures an H4 uh the
thing is okay you might have Knight to
F5 check you might have Knight H5 check
but the absolute best is Knight back to
F1 the problem with Knight stage H5
check is that the King goes forward King
to G6 now attacking the Knight and where
do you go this is covered this is
covered
uh you have to go all in with Knight
captures on F6 and even though it looks
great Rook to G1 now completely cuts off
the king the bishop slices over this way
the queen can get into the game uh F4 is
coming uh black just defends this by
force for example Queen to h8 uh the
absolute best move quanta F4 you will
play Rook capture Sun E4 and now after F
captures an E5 check Rook captures 95
and queen to F4 you have Bishop to F5
and you don't have to worry about a
thing even Bishop to D4 which looks
incredible it doesn't do all that much
just King to E6 and that's it the best
you have is to trade Queens otherwise
you're just uh much worse for example
captures captures and captures and now
you have a rook against the bishop and
Knight but black is of course um of
course much better here so after G
captures on H4 you should play Knight to
F1 and now okay the game continues nice
the G5 comes then Knight comes to E3
Knight captures and F3 attacks the queen
but you will deliver a check and then
pick up the rook and C4 and this comes
with check of course Knight back to G5
now you capture and c4b captures and
let's say Pawn to H3 uh sorry uh or even
Ponte H3 before capturing yeah Queen the
G3 now you capture on C4 and it's a fine
position for both the white and black so
G capture is an H4 a move where you
really have to calculate but both of
them were very low on time
so instead Queen to each it was played
and it looks like a fine move uh just
aligning the queen nicely with the white
king but now Fabi get another big gets
H5 in and okay Queen to H7 now comes
King to G2 with Queen to H6 and now King
the F2 so just improving the position of
the black king white king a little bit
uh Pawn to G4 busting open the position
completely and offering a queen trade
but not Rebecca decides against the
queen trade or uh uh or rather uh he he
pushes The Black Queen back so Queen
back to h8 F captures and G4 we have
Queen to C8 now threatening Queen to C2
and it doesn't look all that great for
another back here he plays Bishop to C5
because uh of course he does not want to
have the queen Enduro connected on the C
file but now Bishop captures and G4 by
Fabi we have Rook to F1 and the bishop
to H3 challenges The Rook Rook to G1 now
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries here King to H7 and now
Ponte H6 and now look at this we have
Queen to G4
and it looks like you shouldn't be doing
this because the queen is now nicely
aligned with the Rook also Rook to G7
might be happening uh Knight to F5 and
believe it or not black is still better
here Queen captures an E4 you don't care
about na Rook to G7 check uh this is
exactly what another bit goes for but
now King to h8 and you cannot touch the
Knight here if you capture the Knight
here then you get checkmated Queen to G2
with check and then after King E3 or you
go to E1 and then Queen to F1 is
Checkmate Queen to G1 check Queen to F2
now Rook the C3 check and even after
King to D2 as the bishop guards the
queen you uh are uh this is met with
Queen the C1 check or King T2 and now a
nice mate and two queen to be to check
King wherever and Rook to C1 of course
will be Checkmate so you can't do that
unfortunately at night the E3 uh so you
have to bring the Knight back to help
out with the defense of the king nakam's
Knight captures on H6 threatening King
captures and G7 and another back trades
Knight captures on C4 uh it's hard to
say whether this is better better than
just bringing the Rook to help out with
the defense but of course they were very
low on time here King captures on G7 and
now Bishop to f8 with check with King
captures Queen captures and H6 with
check King the G8 and now we have uh
okay probably Queen characters on H3 is
objectively best but even after B
captures and C4 you will you will have
to fight very hard to to save this game
black is up two pawns uh you you will be
able to cut off the black king
completely but um okay it's black will
be fighting for a win where white can
survive this or not all depends on on
how you play this so okay you might even
have some B5 ideas creating a pass point
of your own but black would be better
however after King to Jade Knight the E3
was played and here the position is
completely fine for another back unless
unless Fabi finds the only move that
wins and this is not an easy move to
find this this truly is a miracle move
so if you haven't seen you guys will
enjoy this one feel free to pause the
video and try to find this miracle move
uh while I give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
foreign
to do it congratulations on being a true
Miracle Worker and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Bishop
to F5 yes of course your Bishop is
hanging I'm sure everyone saw that but
finding the exact Square for the bishop
cannot be uh easy to find and the reason
for this is that it prevents Queen
captures on F6 if uh another black had
Queen captures on F6 then he would be
fine for example if you play something
like busher back to E6 or Bishop to D7
uh then uh just Queen captures an F6 and
the white is perfectly fine however
after this bishop the F5 move this is
impossible because of the simple trick
Queen to F4 check and now you either go
to the dark squares and the blunder the
Knight with check or you go to a light
squirrel it's a king E2 and then Bishop
D3 check picks up the White Queen so
that's the problem with Bishop to F5
another but played the the objectively
best move Queen to H5 but it doesn't um
it doesn't save him a bishop to G6 now
cuts off the queen completely from
checking the black king queen to H 3 and
now okay you could win a lot of ways you
could just grab a pawn here but Pawn to
F5 makes sense you wanna continue
cutting off the the white king queen
from attacking the black king queen back
to H6 now even King the F7 just
defending the bishop Queen to h8 and now
Queen to D4 now pinning the Knight now
preparing F4 to win material uh so King
to eat you Pawn to F4 and now Knights
the G for hoping for some sort of a
miracle here uh but uh it just doesn't
exist Pawn to F3 check and it was in
this position and move 62 that noted by
Cabo Sato resigned to the game as there
is nothing more to be done here so
absolutely a crazy game uh Fabi said in
an interview that at some point he had
no idea what was happening if he was a
better worse what was going on but um in
the end he was the one who who emerges
triumphant out of this tactical Skirmish
so here you resign because okay you're
in check if you do nothing you're just
gonna lose the Knight you if you if you
capture you're going to lose also lose
the Knight Queen to F4 with check you're
just gonna move captures with check now
you're done a piece and a pawn so uh
completely winning so really really
crazy game could have gone either way
but um I thought it was just able to you
know uh better navigate uh through this
madness and then another back uh what
this means is that as Fabi was leading
um at the pack going into round six he
is still leading as he's the only one
who won his gaming classical we're gonna
discuss the standings and the other
encounters and the live ratings uh but
yeah of course as you might imagine uh
now Fabi is again world number two in
classical chess in the live ratings uh
SC color did not win his classical game
and Fabi did but yeah we're going to
discuss that as we are covering some
other games from round six uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh Fabi aside from that you know misstep
in the previous round is playing a
perfect tournament
I would like to thank mihel Zakaria as
David gasparian and Brandon fukuda
Andres felonus and Rocky Johnson for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
uh wonderful tournament until it
finishes yeah so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and once again big
congratulations to everyone who found
the bishop to F5 as it really is a
spectacular move uh see you soon